hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's air on flash QA I know
there's a lot of questions about what's
going on with caitlin snow and all the
arrow questions are really all over the
board you know how's Oliver still alive
what's going on with Rachel cool how is
it going to tie in with the back half of
the season so I'll try to get to
everything next week is going to be
another vertigo based episode but we
also have details on episodes 14 and 15
so i'll talk about that after i get
through questions okay so just careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen them yet does we work our
way through questions so here we go
raphael s what do you think is going to
happen to give Cisco and Caitlin their
vibe and killer frost abilities I think
dr. wells was lying when he told the
press he wouldn't or he wasn't trying to
turn the particle accelerator brake on
so there's a couple things that could go
on here basically what I've seen from
greg berlanti in the the producers is
that they just want to let caitlin and
cisco be caitlin and cisco for now so no
powers season 1 is what I think is going
to happen that doesn't mean they won't
ever get powers but I think they're
building the Caitlin snow character out
inside this fire star mark so once they
establish firestorm then they'll
transition to a more Caitlin centric
storyline to answer your question about
the particle accelerator there's really
two ways you could go on that so one he
could not need to build another one
because he only needed to create the
first Barry Allen the other side of that
too is that you could say yet he might
need to turn it back on to do some
cosmic treadmill time-travel stuff I
really have no idea how they're going to
explain this time travel we'll find out
in episode 15 that'll be like the first
time we see time travel so presumably
the reverse-flash well time travel the
same way that the flash does but because
Barry won't need the particle
accelerator to be on to time travel I
don't think the reverse flash will need
to do that either I may have explained
it in my episode 11 video but if you
look at Barry Allen from the perspective
of being the originator of the Speed
Force it's possible that Harrison wells
only needed to create the particle
accelerator to create the flash they
might choose to go another route with
the way they explain it because the
Speed Force is also like another
dimension in and of itself you can get
trapped inside the Speed Force that'd be
really awesome way to leave off the
season you can let me know if you agree
do you want to see the reverse-flash
trap Barry inside the Speed Force this
season next question mark s who do you
think will be in the
do you think that they'll have people
with powers or use tech based villains
well I think it'll be a combination of
both Tech and metahuman based abilities
as for the relative composition of the
Rogues I don't think there's going to be
that many this season we have heat wave
Captain Cold and now golden glider
captain cold sister so at least those
three Pied Piper is kind of a loner so I
don't know that he's necessarily going
to team up with the other rogues this
season but that's a possibility then
there's always the possibility that the
reverse-flash could use the Rogues that
would necessarily mean him joining the
Rogues they can form a temporary
alliance to be honest though I'd rather
see them use captain colds gun to take
down the reverse-flash next question bar
to ask what are Batman Superman doing
are they even in this DC arrow flash TV
universe well yes there in the universe
is just that because of licensing rights
they're not allowed to mention them on
screen specifically by name like Clark
Kent Bruce Wayne the simplest way to
look at it is that Bruce Wayne is of a
comparable age to Oliver Queen so if
Oliver Queen is going through his
initial permutations before he becomes
the Emerald Archer before he joins the
Justice League assume the Batman is at a
similar stage of development or if you
really want to nitpick and say that
Bruce Wayne is still going to join the
League of Assassins at some point you
could say that Bruce has almost gone to
Nanda Parbat like he's not quite there
yet just in general terms assume the
entire DC universe exists inside the
arrow verse it seems kind of silly but
think about it this way arrow isn't so
much a comic book show as it's the wire
with a comic book character in it
someone asked Marc Guggenheim about his
favorite TV shows and he said the wire
and Sons of Anarchy so don't think of
arrow so much as being a DC show is
being a drama with a couple DC
characters in it so they follow the
logic of traditional drama more than
they do comic book logic it's always
hard to explain why they don't have
Barry Allen on speed dial all the time
but the simplest answer is is that it
would ruin all their stories it's harder
to tell human drama when you have
unlimited power that's why it's so hard
to get a Superman movie right so that's
that's why arrow is kind of stayed away
from powers although they're slowly
changing their tune next question hen
bot s is no one getting rather disturbed
by the fact that they're locking up all
these people without lose rights
sunlight trial or anything so
yeah I definitely think that the show is
going to address this they're trying to
do the right thing but they're still
figuring things out so they're going to
make a lot of mistakes let's not forget
about the idea of the prison break too
if you were the reverse-flash and the
flash was one of the only people that
could defeat you how would you deal with
him so that you could carry out some
secret plan and keep him from stopping
you one easy way to distract him would
be to release all those metahumans at
the same time team flash would be so
busy dealing with them they probably
wouldn't be able to deal with the
reverse-flash that doesn't mean that's
what the reverse flash is planning on
doing I think that the reverse flash
Harrison wells that is is going to enter
into a Malcolm Merlyn Oliver situation
with Barry at a certain point Barry
still doesn't know what's going on so
they're going to have that moment first
but I think Harrison will appeal to
Barry's emotions and he'll be grudgingly
help him next question no more ass so
did Barry take a peek like Caitlin
suggested well I kind of think he did
like like a little bit very briefly but
I think he's trying to forget about it
as he said he still hung up on iris so
thinking of Caitlin in a romantic way it
just isn't on his radar it's pretty
believable that a dude would be pretty
dense about that too just not notice
that a girl was into him very so busy
trying to get faster as the flash and
deal with iris he doesn't see Kaitlyn
that way but yes he totally sneaked a
brief peek there's no one that would not
have peaked next question me John ass I
actually thought of Killer Croc when
they went underground actually uh the
comic book the flash season 0 comic book
this week had king shark in it so I
think that they're just slowly teasing
into the crossbreed metahumans when I
say that I mean I mean like genetic
experiments they could also be teasing
something going on underneath central
city like metahumans crawling around in
the sewers I like that idea too it would
be really cool if Gorilla Grodd created
gorilla City in the sewers beneath
central city without team flash knowing
about it okay next question so I'm
moving into arrow related stuff now so
Layla willow asks still waiting for an
explanation on how Oliver's alive again
wasn't he stabbed in the chest now we
see bandages over his stomach Danny's
saying to Laurel you're lucky I don't
kill women and now we see him explaining
how he killed Malcolm's wife and he was
all happy about it ok so just working
down your list the place that Ray Shaw
ghouls stabbed him
was probably like in just the right
place like Oliver got lucky plus katana
probably had some really awesome healing
skills I did see some confusion a lot of
people thought that he got stabbed in
the heart he got stabbed on the other
side of his chest and it was really like
kind of just below his rib cage so if he
got stabbed in any critical organs it
was one of his lungs and you could still
survive with just one lung working
usually when they lay things down in the
writers room they make complete sense
but by the time it gets filmed edited
and it airs on television it's changed a
whole bunch so if there's any
inconsistencies is just a function of
the production process after the break
thing not killing women you can look at
it a couple different ways one he could
not be killing women anymore like maybe
he used to co woman and created that
policy after he became the break that we
see right now or option two he could be
an unreliable narrator he could just be
lying through his teeth next question
gorilla ms who do you think will be
resurrected in the Lazarus Pit my money
is on Tommy or Rachel goal so arrow
actually they did build a Lazarus Pit
set in episode 4 we see him getting out
of like a hot tub looking thing I don't
know if that's the Lazarus Pit they were
talking about let's just assume that it
is for a minute because they said they
also make a lot of hot to time machine
jokes I feel like the biggest WTF they
could do that would be really awesome
way to end the season is if someone like
Merlin ends up killing Rachel goal and
then Nyssa dumps his body in the Lazarus
Pit regardless of how racial goal is
dealt with if anyone's going to get to
use it it's going to be him next
question Felix butcher asked my favorite
scene was when lance and Arsenal we're
talking and Lance was like I'm not
stupid I know it's you Roy yeah that was
really funny I feel like that's just
teeing up the Black Canary reveal he's
going to figure out that Laurel is the
Black Canary it's just a way for the TV
series to tell us that Quentin is a very
smart person he's a good detective so if
he wants to learn someone's secret
identity he's going to learn it I feel
like the line gets drawn at the arrows
identity though in the comics there been
various points where Jim Gordon seems
like he knows who Batman is and he
probably does but openly he says he
doesn't want to know next question
potato chip ass when are they going to
bring in all of her son that he doesn't
know about there's a couple ways to
think about this they could bring him on
as part of a family arc in the future
season I feel like this season's already
too crowded with characters so bringing
him on probably wouldn't help
option two is for like another flare Oh
reveal like the arrow flash crossover in
following seasons like seasons four or
five six you know whatever until they're
ready to actually bring the kid on in a
major arc next question Brian asks is
there going to be another flash and
arrow crossover well so this season
episode 18 is going to be an atom flash
crossover so kind of flash arrow
crossover but it'll be very adam
specific the big crossover that you
might be talking about the flitter
across over there gonna do that every
year it'll come before the mid-season
finale every year they'll keep doing
that as long as the arrow on the flash
are on air the CW just said it was like
the most successful thing they ever did
so yeah definitely lots more arrow flash
crossovers but it's only going to be a
once a season kind of thing next
question peons asked what do you think
Slade's significance is this season
isn't he supposed to make an appearance
in episode 14 I'd really like to see a
slave versus ratio goal fight so Slade
is going to be in an island episode
that's going to be episode 14 the return
I'm gonna read the synopsis for episode
14 right now Malcolm puts Oliver and
Thea in a dangerous situation that lands
them on Lian Yu with Oliver's former
enemy Deathstroke so we don't know what
that dangerous situation that Merlin
throws them in I'm just guessing this
Slade gets out and they end up fighting
a little bit in slate gets away and
since we've been talking about the atom
suit a lot and the Nanda Parbat here's
actually the description from episode 15
if you guys haven't read it Malcolm is
captured by Ray Shaw goal and taken to
Nanda Parbat because of his love for
Thea Oliver consider saving Merlin then
back in Starling raised obsessed with
finishing his atom suit so he can save
the city but Felicity fears he's heading
down the same path is Oliver and tries
to pull him out of the lab I know that
sounds kind of opaque but it is
something to get really excited about
but thank you so much everyone that
submitted questions these are always a
ton of fun to do don't forget lots of
big stuff happening this weekend so we
have a game of thrones special Walking
Dead is coming back be sure to subscribe
to get all that stuff I'm gonna try and
do some gameplay for that game of
thrones telltale Game on my twitch
channel this weekend too maybe tomorrow
just in case you guys haven't seen them
yet you can click here for this week's
flash episode and here for this week's
arrow episode thank you so much for
watching so I'll see you guys this
weekend high fives
you